this is because we've done it lay on a
red horse man we're gonna do that we're
gonna fill you full of blue Smiley's
that we're good this isn't tonight it's
too late for this
okay now Louisiana get whatever you want
mate yes I'm sure got these simple
healer in there as well just you treat
this as well to try anything to make you
feel if anyone's a youtuber sweeties got
more money that is Lord to do with no
he's robbing a brand new hat this
morning would you dropping them or
saying walk dogs dropped in the morning
me you almost looked at it you owe me
some that I found out today you've got
hurt joggers they've got semen and blood
on them as a diet as a picture
no the Gospels oh man select Brittany
say is the sentence correct or not Paul
has a pair of joggers that have got
someone else's semen and government
that's correct that's right friend but
you say it's it's a sense of fact though
yeah but it's it's the cover off the
Metallica album the one it's like a weed
graphic me only with the details details
details we've got different islands
didn't he have some lucky
[Laughter]
I'm just saying you either by order by
about 15 seconds you should know this
but no [ __ ] major fire safety at old
hope what the difference between phone
and what was the difference between
phones a lot better
walking Swiss Army knife between
survived almost any like like
your Scottish version of meat recipes
and anyway she's bigger than it's or
nothing today
so basically she's like just hammering
all these sponsors
basically with you yeah so I guess by
way of introduction what would be
probably quite nice with Lisa here
I'm gonna guess how the three of us are
on the table you've been involved across
the longest yeah the long we saw me an
important and probably Tim so can you
tell us a little bit about your
introduction as well yes I started back
in like 2009 2009
I did like running before that so for
about six to eight weeks before monie
cross managed to do my long-distance
running so not super long distance at
what you did but um like 10 miles half
marathons things like that
yeah but basically I had like a goal
that I wanted to achieve and which I did
and then I just go so he's ruined the
greatness of 120 and so I ran it in hell
I run it in 120 but I was awaiting on
the whole you know I was like 70 a lot
smaller and smaller than no smaller than
Oh
Sode imagine but so I did that and then
I just I was just bought of it really
that kind of obviously training for like
that sort of distance he had to put road
two miles in its me at the time yeah so
I just got bored saw something for
something else to do so I was messing
around there like kettlebells and stuff
and then I read an article which if it
wasn't like men's fitness on men's
health what you're like 2009
mm like late 2009 early 2010
so I read an article in I think it was
meant self immense fitness about the 300
the the and the 300 guys yep how they
training CrossFit we've mentioned it and
I thought what's up right like Google
CrossFit and and just fun goes to those
two gyms and the Northeast so there's
one called CrossFit northeast England
yeah which is just up in there working
for you and then it was cross the tank
side yeah so um I went to both of them
across the North East England the guys
were great brute was just too far for us
to travel yeah cross the tines how he
was pacing and no shield so it was a lot
closer that's what for me so I went
there and after about a year not even
after about six months I came the by on
the gym so I ended up buying the
affiliate just through circumstances
obviously at the time it was a lot
different to him but it is now something
is like no equipment like literally like
one bar jump on the plate and some
cattle wells and some mutton not was it
something cost a long way and that was
it yet had bought up and then just kept
on training and kept on me kind of
trying to grow the business
no we moved to Benton and we had a money
Newton been and they're not the kind of
interrupts well intrude on what falls in
the saber back in like 2013 moves 2040
Paul came on full-time and has like our
head coach yeah we booked us for time so
it so and then had to be him since then
so for me really
by God but I got into it back in 2009
and started trying to compete with 2010
and then just compete it all the way
through that and when you say stop sort
of started competing you mean it was I
made it to regionals like however many
years
but it was a lot different than also
like the first year that I went to like
the wasn't in Auburn so it was a
sectional slightly you just put your
name on the half either region paid and
you put your name and a hat and you
turned up and competed so there was no
qualification process you for the
Senators like this is kind of like a
like a sedum would be for a local
cottage yeah yeah so you basically paid
him money
you rocked up it was like three workouts
in one day and then from there it was
like the type of time there was three
sectionals so it's like one in the UK UK
and Ireland then there was one in like
Western Europe one Eastern Europe and
then all those three was three people
from each I think went no sorry 20
people from each went to a regional and
then from the regional thing that was
three people from that then went to the
games and then so this was before the
old I was 2010 yeah and then after that
2011 that worth looking on so this was
like pre open so that was the first
proper Competition Act it was sectionals
so I think it was twenty qualified for
regionals and I think I was kidnapped I
first had just missed out on tuition was
that good yeah and so you mister take me
to taken to it pretty quickly
yeah well again at the time when it was
super low skill so like not yeah that
2010 was the first year that due to the
silks and just about politics came up to
work so I wanted that competition I did
not just blah blah so it's basically
stripped like strict pull-ups and it was
booze we had one on the basketball court
was like in the middle of a park yeah
it's like totally different to what it
is now when I'm at a stadium makeup
judges and it's all online and laughter
it's like completely different world
yeah so back then it was like literally
just on a school field in a pod it was
cool we talked a lot less polished
yeah it was just make it up as you go
huh trying to get it in before my dark
soap all over you actually some of its
bits in and Jordan in the sense they're
probably the 300 yeah that's probably a
very big moment for most people and
fitness when it all wasn't CGI I think a
lot of you know
matapedia Jarrah but this formed the
basis for a simple business and he
wasn't even really did they prosperity
him same so I've been that I kind of
watched a film I'd already realize I was
pretty over where and I've already
started trying to let go of all budgets
and things to try and change that and as
a result going to the fitness side I
like got interested in the Venice I'd
lost quite a bit away and then I think
when the 300 went like you know I don't
know whether it was in the internet all
the DVD extras or something like that
there was an interview matt white he was
jim jones
yeah at the time he did it and he
started talking about functional
training and functional movement and
training with cow bells and ropes and
sleds and all i can it all that kind of
stuff so from that and I actually bumped
into a friend one night a guy called
Finn he was doing some strong run
training kind of with job and at the
time all in the facility Sylvia
yeah in the same facility and he was
like ah man I was like a cowbell seems
like oh you should come down
try this gym so I kind of went on the
Internet so I was run by this little kid
who's like doing double unders with an
infidel teacher I was like okay I'm
gonna I'm with her right I'm gonna go
see what this is about
drop them a message and and that was it
went down and got through it through
like a seven-minute workout which like
ruins life time I asked ollie like I
signed up the next day signed up there
and then actually I was like I put the
money in the bag
this is the movie had the money in my
bag there and there now literally it was
just like I'll pay per month and candy
just went went from there again like
like he says I I eventually it was kind
of got more involved he was really
involved in the compare side yeah and I
think like he says like it was easier it
gets the competitive side of time and
even I did okay in the first yeah it's
like the guys got more interested now I
got more interested in the coaching side
I didn't listening to the max whites and
reading and all hosting class so yeah I
just kind of kind of naturally wanted to
go across that okay I we program for
people so we just kind of like his he
grew as an athlete I kind of just
focused more on the coaching side I
interested me a little bit more than
being an athlete personally I wanted to
Train I wanted to do it but I just
wanted to I was interested in how things
work together and what we're doing so
how are you some minds a bit of a weird
one
so my friends started it just started
doing Crossfit in a global gym and it's
garbage
so I started just dealing with it right
tygo I'm joined in and um I was like 18
at the time since 2012 yeah it wasn't
really much going on like we couldn't do
any wall balls we couldn't really lift
heavy you couldn't go overhead
especially his garage if it rained
couldn't stop so we've never done a wall
ball or snap tree
we've done some clean but like horrific
cleans and then he started to open his
own easily then we kind of traveled from
that Teesside every now and then until
he opened up his own
2013 k times up for uni and from that
bit like history yeah so she started
training
try and train twice a day between uni
between
choose case even there then I'm just
humble Estrella yeah got one Paul quite
well did my level one sucker train at my
friend's gym back home yeah then the air
off there just kind of stuck hey that's
right it's at the coach time site every
Wednesday yeah Wednesday and I
understand a little bit with Paul on
Monday symptom Wednesday Cynthia
Wednesday's yes I died of the narrow you
just kind of like you just kind of call
coach for me for a bit video and it was
like okay Wednesday's Wednesday's
already I think one of the things that
struck me when I started was CrossFit as
managed to brand itself so effectively
and I think when anything's that
polished there's an element that people
have got that makes them feel reserved
about something you know the the style
looks so good that the substance can't
be up to scratch does that make sense
the people sometimes a little bit
suspicious when it looks and using the
tag the fittest on earth like it sounds
it sounds impressive and also unbelief
listen yeah yeah so in your opinion are
cross the athletes the fittest athletes
on the planet now I do think it I do
think they kind of print like trying to
produce the fish on earth in the sense
of it's such a broad broad spectrum and
it's the only thing that's really
challenging or testing this broad broad
spectrum there isn't anything else that
is if there's no go around isn't it yeah
I think they look around a bit
and I think the people is producing who
are like you know pretty damn awesome
weight lifters I'm pretty dumb we're
pretty pretty strong power lifters and
can run man can run half-marathons yeah
can do all of that stuff I mean there
just isn't a testing like you're talking
about a terribly atomic EFI to last not
this year ever see what you want with
the air before like did the CrossFit
Games came second and then went can't be
any real the Olympics [ __ ] unless you
realize that enjoy this thing yes
come with it at the highest level in two
sports within two weeks of each other
she hasn't chosen peaked for the work
for the Olympics you know like Dave
Castro just right what can I do to make
me feel like you want to die yeah so
like when you look at it like that from
that point of view yeah it fits on earth
but it depends what you define for
yourself because you know nothing if the
definition of fitness that CrossFit is
used seems quite appropriate to me yeah
like it's worked pass of you across
broad time and modal domains right yeah
yeah I supposed it based on that
definition of fitness and I can't think
of one that's better
like they treating my area of expertise
or petros of terminology you know you
could have like you know you can add new
semantics or whatever I even beyond
these people who can just delve into it
try and pick it apart he's just making a
point about you should be very tired oh
man it's different a lot of different
law domains different movements you know
different plans of movement functional
stuff I mean that's pretty I mean it's
pretty broad I mean it's a broad
description and you can argue it and you
can go into it and you see people a lot
of time trying to pick it apart I think
that's what it is I think the main thing
it was like there should be anything
that you can't do yeah you know me like
I think that's where the broad thing
comes and I think like with Dave Castro
obviously other games like he's
constantly trying to test up and then it
like blows the lines of like competitor
in terms of you don't deserve to be the
fittest to be the best at the sports or
like what I mean by that is like Cameron
in 2000 whatever when when there was a
pegboards he was on the paper smashing
himself trying to get at the top and
failing
she just rested she was about she knew
she was but she wasn't gonna make it
you took this on I is like yeah
rest yeah so it's like that lots work
and you got anything else she's not
actually the face because she can't do
it what you want so you only mean it's
like Rose goes mine's a little bit I
think what's interesting watching from
there open to regionals to the games is
that there's actually a lot less
CrossFit that goes on the higher up you
get yeah it's a lot more CrossFit II at
the local level than it is at the top
level
yeah at the games as well that's so
unlike look II obviously for that for
the open and regionals in some respects
you're pretty limit of what you can do
was like in the open you can't expect
people to be like carrying D walls and
run up hills and stuff like that because
I just can't
how can imagine like how can you make a
run at you if I what you do within those
four walls and with kiss as well and
then regionals it gets a little bit more
kind of out there but still I mean this
year that like the deep walls but in the
past it's really just been dumbbells
barbells kettlebells Ram Ricky yeah
ropes you know what I mean and then the
games it's like right any sense yeah hey
yeah yeah I think what's the new with
the new arena I think it's only gonna
get like more I think the starter or
anything to get better because obviously
the map from a little yeah it's nothing
nothing it's gonna get even more
different things I think it will drop
down as well I think will feed down to
regionals a little bit yeah I think the
swimming is going to be in there pretty
soon more on objects and it's kind of
gonna challenge everything oh how have
you care about that does care
originals I said 1930 heavy nikitos two
or five I think each one so at 93 it's
having one and a half beats no one wants
to pick though so this is press fracking
you'll be shopping though yeah numbers
actually the exact same and I stood back
for life
oh yeah but you won't get started yeah
well so anyone that's tried CrossFit has
done a few of the workouts like hey
regardless of whether or not people like
or don't like cross now I don't think
anyone can deny that really [ __ ] hard
like it like this some of the workouts
that want to ng world I'm I'm really
interested in that we've got three guys
who understand the physiology and with
the standard training methodology as
well I wanted to see if you guys can try
and explain why CrossFit is so hard
like why hurts doing a workout to the
level that it does and if you can try
and take us through maybe some of the
workouts and what it is about there that
just wreck your world because obviously
people can go and run a marathon and
they can come out the other side of it
and maybe the next day they're out there
aches and pains and it's not new that
with during a marathon that's a lot of
people would perceive you know a
pinnacle of realistic yeah local level
of fitness like you know if you gave me
the option of doing that or doing a
couple of the really nasty hero workouts
and like give me the marathon you know I
mean because all the way to use it I
don't know I just think because it's an
honor it's just should be okay maybe
know me but do you understand mom I know
what you're saying yeah thinks I'm like
not from like a science he point of view
Tim's probably best to do that he's not
with the degrees degrees bad memories
put like from degree to Omega from like
a practical point of view I think it's
like so there's so many different
aspects on it so like same with a
marathon it's one foot in front of the
other
that's it like if you can keep putting
one foot in front the other even if
you're walking it you don't even finish
it yeah where it's like with some of the
woods some of the hero workouts like
some of the stuff and that's pretty
challenging so for example like a lot of
them are combining movement saying that
a normal person in the gym wouldn't
combine so I like this one called mr.
Joshua which is like runnin and heavy
deadlifts and then ghd's helps and it's
a pretty simple workout I think it's
like five rounds 400 meter run 15
deadlifts at 1:15 and 30 ghd's it's like
it's a world beater it kills you know
it's like the extension of the deadlift
and then the deflection of that and it's
like through a full range of motion and
then obviously you're running after that
so you help with breath coming in
picking up a moderately heavy load and
then jumped on the GG set which in
itself is a pretty brutal movement like
it's a massive range of motion and it's
not really something that a lot of
people have done before anyway and a
great way to get rhabdo but I think
those types of like combinations of
movements I just brought just Brule you
know it's the same in fact there's
another one called bull which is like a
mile run 50 overhead squats I think at
6,200 double unders and that the 50
pull-ups I think like all that overhead
work and then double unders and then
running into your shoulders gonna be
tired on that and you're like so think
of the squats it's like the combination
of movements are just bro
throw a line with like the attitude of
the environment you're in as well even
if you're not training with other people
it's the environment that you know other
people of doing this workout will handle
is what
so you notice times to beat the stars to
be you're not going to drop you fall and
you meet your running pair so you're
going to keep the intensity diets or
psychological aspects of it throw it in
with the sort of like that competition
environment you know and I'm not saying
that the competition is good or bad and
people are comment about that but it is
you will maintain a high level of
intensity to not work out as a result of
like external factors it's irrelevant
whether or not other people in the class
are doing it there's a heritage of other
people that also is a hero exactly
someone's died they say that's like
paying you're paying tribute minutes a
hero we're gone even we don't believe in
that type of stuff you start gonna go
high so think you know the reason I call
it a tribute so CrossFit this new
Lawrence but you went out doing that
long run against somebody you're doing
it against your previous Scott you know
you're in a 5k going to get your
previous score doing it against Timmy
and it's super wide running get and leg
Johnny and you do it up off when you're
doing in case during the hill or like
the sixth day and so your intensity is
going to be high like your intensity on
that 5k you would apply yourself but why
appeared argue people that were informed
and meters that I think I'm right in
saying that 400 music quite commonly
known as the worst running distances yes
yeah
then you've got to go pick a bottle up
yeah right okay but my point is that if
someone's got the exhaustion or 400 on a
400 movements like obviously you can add
load and you can do all the rest of the
things is it is it the combination of
movements is that what makes it so
terrible it takes it yeah with the
muscular
like let's put out there as well like
newbies go anaerobic quick and trying to
breathe when you go out of row but it's
not gonna hop excellent miles so you
just go really hot and hot right to
through the reef try and hold something
on the front rock compressing you
breathing and for you trying to breathe
when you had a row of it it's not gonna
happen like Jordan these they can master
it pacing he doesn't go out of robic at
any point all the road yeah it kills me
so he saves himself like oxygen flowing
through his body it's not restricted at
any point so he can move throughout it
whereas say your first session yeah I
put you on the assault bike to start off
with yeah you're probably gonna go out
the Cape pretty hot yeah then you've got
your deadlifts then you got your burpees
yeah yeah do you know what's coming well
I think the thing is he told me you
don't even know what going on aerobic
means yeah like it took me six months to
find out that you're supposed to I'm
right in saying you're supposed to try
and right unless you sprint you're not
finishing right dribble on the other
than yeah where everyone will be freshly
yeah right okay so what for anyone who
needs advice on how the pace what is the
I have a threshold and how definitely
the wrong patient like so I was like
yeah I bought an aerobic net in a wall
so what happens what what is it that
causes you to go on a road with and what
is it so I don't anaerobic is literal
definition without oxygen so your body
doesn't have oxygen so it's trying to
contract the muscles here in there so
this it can do this is what you've done
too much work is a shorter space it's
yeah and yeah now working instead of
being a roaming which are more efficient
yes yeah you're not being the presence
of oxygen now you look in anaerobic so
you basically don't know you're in
emergency mode
Yeah right here so how is it why he's
pacing in how do you do it I think a lot
of it it's like knowing what you can do
so like in a lot of the open workouts
people will be like with me especially
possibly go faster go I'm like no I'm
Nolan David I've got on my pace
I don't wanna go at your pace I'm on my
face because I know on this place and go
hard for 30 minutes yeah 40 minutes
whatever it may be
yeah if I go a little bit faster now no
that's the workout like let's talk let's
take what 17.4 is at the dead with one
yeah the 55 mean you did that I've got a
funny story about this that I'll dip in
very quickly I got off the 55 that list
of 100 hundred two hundred two kilos
yeah and you programmed this me earlier
in the week Vinh Phuc there's hundred
two kilos and then straight out of the
walls I've chewed 55 moles at nine kilos
and I broke on the wall balls at 32 here
you're going to you 28 29 I was like oh
my god we just allow so much like go
past do not paste ahead of Jordan exact
idea
so yeah you were saying in that so it's
like like on those deadlift Tom chef did
not work out before the three times
before because it was a repeat that did
it twice in 2015 I think it was 2060 and
then I did it once in training on the
build-up to the last year's open yeah so
I did not work out and I knew how to
paste that work out so I knew that the
$55 million in the certain
time the 55 I'm not very good at wall
balls so I can push a little bit harder
on the deadlifts and paste it on the
wall and then the classic thing with
George's trips people up which is one
thing that where I was trying to
communicate across to people is the roll
so like on the rower you could sit I'd
say like 80% effort and pull say 12 and
recoveries on the omelette on the mono
1200 calories so that might take it
let's this is not the exact number
that's it degree minutes our fault
that's it takes you two minutes 32 roll
55 calories yeah
or you can sit at 95% effort and have
enough 1400 calories and finish it in
250 but then you need to take 45 seconds
after I have a rest before you get on
the handstand push-up so it's like no
one we're pushing weight or not yeah
does that make sense yeah they'll be
like certain movements within a workout
where you can go hard on my max
basically and it's just through
experience just like anything through
experience of knowing where pushing
weight relax
so like in that workout that's actually
quite a good example to use for me
personally so the deadlifts are quite
from floor with obviously small like
short range of motion the wigs not like
heavy it's quite to moderate and the
walls kill me I'm a [ __ ] and a tire
target the roll not great ass
because I'm small and I've got small
range of motion again so obviously a
continence the handle as well as someone
who's taller and then the handstand
push-ups are really good because I'm
it's a short range of motion again yeah
and I'm white
so it's like it's two out of the four
that are good Intel for that bad and you
need to know where you go exactly
blazing capitalizing weight Kong again
with that too should be there's two
others on that that you can catch your
breath more by going more easily on the
movements that are easy to you you know
and pushing Otago do this is this
just like like you've gotta find it for
yourself yeah yeah this is like stimulus
like babes though based on like that's
competing yeah you know like we do
workouts they're anaerobic on purpose
yes because you were trying to trick
train all the man's right so we've got
strength workouts we've got the power
workout so we've got those anaerobic
efforts the spring months oh I wanted to
ask this question do the workouts there
in CrossFit as far as for why no split
up in two broad categories yeah break it
down into three we brick probably break
it down into it for two maybe through
them so we're talking like strength work
so we've got like a maximal ethics
usually like a compound movement or we
might train Olympic lifters that so
you're talking like you have any box
what is the channel powerhouse Krim work
outlet and glycogen work Michael so
there you go all right now it goes so
our anaerobic capacity work so these are
the short shaft workouts so five minutes
so three hands so more than bikes to
less than that even like five seconds to
work why can't any work this is the
remember this is just true yeah this is
just training so this is training
adaptation so these are general Fridays
when we put you in teams so when you get
we die and what we like we try and force
you into breaking it down it does these
ridiculous little spritz which really
new yeah you know I've done it with you
before a couple of times yeah yeah what
it's like I don't development I mean it
just looks like camaraderie and good fun
but it's actually an entire day
exactly and like the boiler in your team
nah people in your team the more rest
you get the more the more maximal your
effort give me on yet so the better
adaptation we get then we've got the
power endurance work so they have robic
kind of like high in the robic work
which is more like your four minutes
your eight minutes your twelve minutes
like Helen it's like a wave form to me a
run 21 couple swings 12 pull-ups three
rounds of time so it's a really quick
nurse used to break really and should be
like Soviet minutes this is what we live
sport as well yeah we so we call these
[ __ ] like play across pit but that's
because in the open typically workouts
are between 5 minutes and 20 minutes
long so we've trained up some mixed
modality for like at five times I think
there were cops five minutes cleaning
jokes well snow there's so many cameras
we need like 2010-11 to visible and then
workouts typically now like 20 minutes
kind of vibes these are where you're
like 80% be working aerobic Li I think
if you go into I never think in those
workouts that's when you've gone off too
quick and you spend the next so is this
one point when hazing would be yeah I
said it would be okay but obviously but
then this you're not going to be pacing
if you get to a barbell and it's at 80%
of your warmer at max clean because
you're doing a sport that's you know
they've still they're aware and I'm not
like you know the top-tier athlete yeah
although I'm sitting you're gonna hit
that barbell and you're not going to be
tapping into the same net energy system
is the big strong guy who's got 120 kilo
snatch you know you're going to tapping
into something a little bit different
the workouts and it feel different you
know that's when it's like game all the
time
and then we've got our aerobic
development work so the pure aerobic
that's our M Jane Fonda long workouts
kind of like you know the knee big long
runs and things like that so we've got
these domains that we're hitting all the
time so the SIP here thing is is
relevant to where you are because I make
sense yes
and that's when we program as well but
what a program that we do we just have
like a tick list you know just tick one
of those off yeah depending on the
period elevation of the year now we're
getting into the sport neck of the woods
with the open seven
weeks away so we're totally by Cigna I
did a minute work that 12-minute not 20
minute work because that's eroding
people in but that's because it has
become approach of the open now we're
approaching for the people were working
with who with flight decided that I
compare this yes they're the people
whether like okay you guys need to be
practicing your spot we need to be
working in that domain that you're going
to be using because we get you to just
before the open and we've never had you
hitting that high end like aerobic work
and you don't know what that feels like
then you know you're going to go into
the open the super revved up super
excited on Friday night light so they
were cheering for you you're going to
don't even I'm a big Jordan you're gonna
get the Dennis before I before you hear
it you know I think what's really
interesting pokey said there about the
multiple body types thing and I think
this is what for me makes it a really
interesting spec to explore that it kind
of feels you know a little bit like we
used to play Mortal Kombat attacking and
everyone have their special moves each
each character had their own special
move that they can see each character
was equal and also unequal the N
different ways and I think that watching
the games and watching it generally is a
sport and also even though you have the
guys in the gym
there's the levels of because the
characters within the gyms within
everyone's a local affiliate that have
got these how he's the strong guy is
there but Thompson he's the gymnastics
yeah for sure yeah and I think what's
really interesting is the fact that you
have these people because this sport is
still relatively young they're coming to
it from so many different disciplines
that it's some people have got unfair
advantages in some areas that lead to
chronic weaknesses another year I had
something yeah so at the moment like you
know watching Zack George who is a you
Catholic between exhorting local cops at
the moment but he's [ __ ] huge is it
then he must be what 220 230 pounds big
lad yeah you've gotta be hundred kilos
always tall as well no he's not got long
link so things like handstand push-ups
and stuff yeah they're not gonna be
great from I'm gonna put this out there
we programmed the worker the comp II he
was at last it was a weighted bar
muscle-ups with the vest yes I still
cannot do one of these
throw that out there as well as fall for
like six years
yeah he's done one ever this this love
it put one on now it's to the side I was
thinking it's not gonna make 9 on bro
witness best so that saves 100 kilo so
that's 110
yeah strong boy so he was my point right
that we've got these people that come
into the sport from multiple different
disciplines yeah as the sport develops
what's going to happen is that people
are no longer going to be transitioning
from a background that background is
going to be CrossFit yeah there's no
work like a under 14 this club enemy
there's like a juniors at the games like
well to touch on that like under
strength and depth earlier in the air
with Reebok there was a guy young like
that we compete with called Reese
Mitchell he went to the games
I think he's in there for for 1516 age
category I think yeah I think it came
second or third yeah
legit like I'm ridiculous but it's 33
bomber slots are broken like snatches 70
kilos clean and jokes one on 560 like
Luke when I was 16 I was like running
just running you know this kid's got
like so much potential to get to where I
want to be but he's also so far ahead of
like looked across first you only think
about normal in James yeah
but people in gym you know someone in
our junior snatchin 70 kilos and clean
joe 105 pretty decent a sling you know
or pretty good capabilities is kids 60
so much of my swing like when he's my
age
yeah it's 25 well you got to think about
coaching as well like when I started at
18
it was just jump up he did I'm sure it's
the same with you guys more just go do
it now the coaching above this guy is
just huge bet like he loved a dedicated
Olympic weightlifting coach he's
CrossFit coach your life programming on
the side of everything on the plate for
him yeah which is gonna make him even
better yeah I mean I think back to some
of the stuff I used to make Paul do oh
my god I'm surprised to sell our life so
this is something else that I wanted to
really touch on so I've seen like some
throwbackthursday images and stuff from
late 2010 can you give me a rundown of
some of the most CrossFit stuff or some
of the most stupid CrossFit stuff you've
done because what's happened now it
feels like 2017 2018 with the sporting
maturity now it's the s like the sports
in maturity yeah and although that's
fantastic because you can live stream
the games on Facebook and it's it looks
like the Olympics and there's a I'm sure
that there will be a full opening
ceremony very soon it's gonna have to be
yeah they're not I mean like there's
gonna be all manner of different bits
and pieces what you don't get are the
mad funny [ __ ] mistakes yeah that occur
during the adolescence sort of sport I
say I think we were super lucky we were
super lucky they you know what yeah you
met like you know the stupid stuff we
don't we did ourselves
yeah pretty like I've been really lucky
better be surrounded by a lot of really
good people so like I had a coach called
Kyle stem and Adams like for I think
it's Microsoft for off years yeah him
engage now see both super knowledgeable
guys Island
a lot of the stuff off them too and that
has helped me so much like a lot like
one thing I was gonna say was I used to
just think that more was better like the
more you did the better you'd be yeah
and then I remember like volume volume
is king I remember like probably about
six years ago now call said it was like
more than that that was just more you
know intensity always Trump's volume so
you're better doing less well then doing
loads crap yeah and that was one thing
I've stuck me for quite a long time and
but I mean I think back to some the
stuff that I used to do like I don't
know how I did it but tell me and tell
me so tell me some of the stupid cross
mr. Ellison I did like all of the girls
in one day so that's like 50 female
workouts just like Nancy on my Nancy
Kelly all those things did all in one
day how much work volume was
made too much second thousand pull-ups
like reading Solomon say 1200 like all
day yeah that's just a different day
this is just stupid by itself
yeah that was a bomb on my own I think
that's very envious at the time did you
do what do you say I was doing what
every hour or something whatever I can't
except one every hour are the short ones
thinking did every half an hour's like
grace Isabelle somewhere and this isn't
this isn't it just fell crack literally
just because it's not a crack it did you
not extreme enough to ridiculous number
of burpees once did thousand take the
Sun every yet four years running tenders
every year Christmas Eve you did a
thousand birthdays on Christmas the
Christmas Day this bad Christmas I think
let me look at the person may not
accident in Christmas Eve once but fat
Clovis was mere Alex might do them half
Martin rule straight into Clovis Clovis
is a ten-mile run 150 per people that
was pretty partition 2197 2197 day they
got twenty-one thousand ninety seven
years so that took like an hour and
twenty five we did bring a TV into the
gym and we watch God the galaxy about
doing it finished it but that was great
but then when you go on a 10-mile and
I've seen hanging on your ass because
you've just ruined half marathon and
someone saw me running down the street
and starts saying that you were you
would well so I at the letters like like
about eight miles in and then I got to
go [ __ ] me i sat in the office for ten
minutes and they in there all of but run
back out
it's working then got in the shower with
wash our the old place just sat in the
shower and the hot water and then I
realized I didn't bring a towel like a
dragon self a blue roll completed stays
well I'm corrected I'm glad to see I
mean some of the guys we went to Vegas
my business partner stag do and we
create you know we thought we create the
sit down shower they're working on I do
this a lot of set up the sit-down shower
it would have here is so versatile yet
yeah
I need anything is applicable for Vegas
hangovers yeah for doing - throwing a
stupid stupid CrossFit workout
I mean if anyone is feeling bad at the
moment all they need to do and then
there you can know looking that which is
the live out shot weight needs to be
mace down face down base which end face
down so you get enough he's not a level
of torture no face your face down fix
time yeah but I'm sure that's fine it's
a great thing that's nice did you do you
did you do one one hour three minutes
forty seven minutes it's I believe you
could have took three minutes up like
that's the slowest I've gone I've got
like I've got less bit every year
coach advisor yellowest yeah what's all
this Wow stupid thing I've ever done is
uh trying to do a clapping strict on
pushup nothing strict hands up there but
I'm sure that everyone can imagine what
happens when you don't make that element
of risk involved I'm pretty sure I lost
an inch pipe would be lucky I think like
injuries and stuff in the job of being
minimum minimal yeah we'd be like the
CrossFit just got a really bad name for
like injuries and stuff but I think it's
like anything but any training gym I
have pertaining to any commercial gym
and show you the loads of crap Petey's
who don't want to do it people went
Frankie left right and center they say
was CrossFit like the will be coach is
out there that all Korea what you're
gonna get out and everything we like to
think that work what what decent what
good you know obviously there's all
those things that we can improve on but
we try and do our best with everything
the thing we do a good job or agree it's
just it gets a bad name through so it is
my sort to pounce on it someone who's
not being in the sport for a year and I
did around about ten months ago so just
as he open started after I've been doing
the two months I went did a podcast with
the guys for proper fit yeah and we kind
of reassessed it everything from there
yes
and really tell you to call this mantra
spitballs I think you should dam and
rename a podcast we just did you know
anyway so I went in and they as
bodybuilding and powerlifting background
you have a bunch of questions and you
you are right that CrossFit gets such a
bad rap and we tried to dissolve now why
it is that we think makes CrossFit first
so polarizing in terms of opinion and
then kind of what gets it the bad
reputation and we can't win number
conclusions one of them is the fact that
I think a lot of people that go in the
gym now especially you guys are in
bludgeons they're conflating an interest
in exercise and sport and fitness with
going into bodybuilding they think that
the only thing that they can do is to go
in and do the curls and do the rest of
it because that has been the prevailing
training methodology for the last thirty
years and the other side of that which
makes it super attractive is it's got
mega low barriers to entry so bring us
back to my industry it's like club
nights if you have a thousand pounds and
the DJ and a venue that's prepared to
let you in you now have a business you
know you cannot go and start the new
iPhone with a thousand pounds of
announced active so anyone can I since
then you know where as you can go in
with a PT for five minutes in a global
gym and you can master a souvenir bicep
curl to 80% of the standard if someone's
been doing three years can do so when
you go into a CrossFit gym and someone
says right okay we're gonna try and do
is snatch and yeah is such a technically
complex movie that the Murrays to entry
is so high that people's egos get shot
down very quickly people don't like to
go and do things at that matter right
they don't want to go in and have but do
something that's difficult they're happy
with difficult but within the parameters
of not necess
yeah yeah feeling like it's unachievable
I think a lot of that comes down to
several factors so first of all the
person's attitude we've got an eagle
cross was probably not the right support
for me it's about an eagle whether
whether think that they should be able
to do everything that's never gonna be
lifted there's people who just do those
two lifts snatch and clean and jerk they
spend their entire life getting better
at the snatch in the collegiate from
being a verdict for effect so how does
Jimmy who's 53 in an accountant so he's
gonna walk in and be perfect that's not
to knock out you've got except that
you're never gonna be you're never gonna
be perfect like I've been doing what no
the eight years now my clean jerk and my
snatch still proud you know I mean it
still needs work everything does you I
think that I think that that's does
what's interesting the fact that I think
there's across food documentary for my
2014 yeah and I can't remember who the
narrator is a tempered citizen voice up
from Dave Castro where he says that very
very soon we're gonna see someone who's
got like a 500 pound deadlift in a sub 5
minute mile and this is the listener
this and that it and he was explaining
this the fact that the sport in terms of
progression for athletes reaching a
ceiling is still yes infancy which I
would absolutely agree with well yeah I
think the that was one of the first
things that I was like I think that it
gets a little bit of a bad rap from some
people because he's daunting because
there's a sensitive elitism associated
with the people that can't do it because
there's a little bit of jealousy and
this is there's a quite rightly like if
song can walk into a gym and do a Muslim
and you've been training bracelets for
six years
and all you can do is a really well
controlled controlled eccentric on a
seat it's like shoulder practice yeah
there is an element if you think like
you look people look that looks good
yeah that is cool and irrelevant of how
you look you like that looks like that
looks really like and you know it is for
me t to look it cross there's a training
methodology last year if you told me the
star the year that I would've seen the
progress I've sought physically from a
bodybuilding program
yeah I told you a lie yeah and I don't
know exactly why is that was the
difference because I've been training to
ten years before that run about in
varying degrees of cerebral innocent
games wrong an awful lot but you know I
mean you the enters away in your heart
and you're going you go in and lifting
things moderately regularly you try to
eat some protein like it just gets bro
science and Muslims yeah moderately
better as you have towards a little bit
and I think what was interesting was
that you now have formalized progressive
overload
you're a formalized amount of intensity
like you have in a basket all of the
things that everyone's trying to achieve
on the other side of the gym in any case
yeah I think what our gym in particular
is quite a good example of it because we
have obviously like three areas large of
our global gym on a regular two of the
box and those are boot camp area which
is like you know it's like it's like
CrossFit button CrossFit like not as
much kind of yet it not works like
complex movement so you know we know
it's all pretty simple you know not all
[ __ ] way to clean your jokes not doing
King muscle up sinister laugh but if you
look the cross bars look the best they
do the lads a big the shredded a jacked
and they're not doing bicep curls like
the guys in there and in the global gym
but they look the best and ultimately
that's everyone's cool
it almost looked good there said the guy
who was sneaking in the bicep curls and
the Bevin of what like too much bench
press for the guy who was still
crosshairs of the guys who come in and
their soul King comes to snatches a [ __ ]
you literally go up to them and you're
just like dude you big body building up
in you and you're like just a little bit
that's always the same thing and that
doesn't mean they can't become
compatible you knows a lot of people who
are doing that now and that's like the
new trendy thing isn't it like
everyone's like functional values you're
looking
look at look at fruit strengths through
body I just think as well on you that's
like the evolution of eyes that people
have started to admit that the fact it's
all K again to say that I want to look
good yeah yeah because I think all that
I CrossFit and like people working their
way through CrossFit I think a lot of
people were yep I'm quite nailed on yeah
and a lot of people were like don't look
good but fit the new or I don't look
great and i think i think that i think
now what's your front i think about a
lot of people would say it look like
maybe a door need to be maybe i'm not
going to be like a retronym and maybe I
need to just step back on the volume and
I do want to just look back and the Sox
you know honestly when I still want a
train and I think they don't want to
actually be able to do the [ __ ] you
you were able to capitalize on the
methodology whilst not wanting or
necessarily but I haven't have the
competition like outside of necessarily
a class like within a master class and
be compared I was also like a common
misconception I think with CrossFit
everyone thinks it's competitive it's
not no it's only competitive if against
yourself is if you do a crisper loosen
and give a big lakes it's gonna be I'm
only joking
I'm gonna be proud but not of you if you
want it to be competitive you know when
you seek out making make new decisions
you can make it competitive but if you
just want to turn up train and go home
it can't just be not as well that's why
we did all that people look at why
bother right yeah and that's why we
don't force workouts like the night
before because we don't want people
being like it's like turn them do the
class yeah that's it no I know each
other things work out in I agree so yeah
I think I think what's really
interesting is that you've got this
you've got this training methodology
which appears to be producing guys that
have got bodies year round they're
better than the physique competitors or
at least on part the only difference is
the fact that then maybe need to go
through like to step on stage if you
have to take this need a walker
James call scum
so when Lauren came to train with us
like what 18 months ago she'd never just
gone for back of doing all the bikini
stuff on stage she's in good Nick
something wrong but she was lean but she
was like weak yes a week
weren't you no idea why she is now she
leaned all the time she's lot stronger
yeah she looks Jack yeah a good way yeah
you know like she looked better now when
I did there and showed not you can do in
a physique for now look it look it so
I'm like done baby like if you peeled
down baby down a little bit and did or
two and Digger two months ago you won't
have a hard two months ago you just sell
me some so you step on stage it classic
bodybuilding yeah you wouldn't step what
you'd be too big to step on the stage
magazine yeah and you like I think I may
not people are like that and this guy is
well renowned as the fastest man in
CrossFit the most in terms it's like
straight line speed or a short other
things the mill means a still cross
there's lose your games yeah like do you
know I mean which is so here's the thing
right this is what we drilled it down to
there is not a brand behind a push for
leg split no no one hashtags which puts
more legs today like in the Instagram
thing and people love to hate on
something that has an identity yes and
this is this is what we think and it's
different as well is it is different
yeah like it's it's definitely high
visibility
yeah you know I mean like people can see
when you doing it rebo meal
but people love it because it's cool
yeah it's good but it came from as well
the whole thing like it's like they
totally call the wave right I mean they
be doing it really long time but with
the social media thing yeah so they did
it all of all that websites when all
this went online thinking you found out
through like a chatroom or whatever
I found out through I just went online
yeah put chat rooms in support I myself
also office Suffolk but it was your
office all this for the government but
and off the back of that that means that
a lot of people poor stupid [ __ ] on
Instagram and tagging across better you
do I mean and then all of a sudden
that's the stuff that gets the attention
yeah
you I mean not the not the thousands of
or care but mediocre like Lord it
snatches that like people have done
really well on our pbteen or improve
that technique but the one where alas
gets a ponytail car in it gets dragged
across the gym now I do really good job
I think of bringing that perception of
it back around so they're not really on
kosher calm now post in like elite level
CrossFitters that post in your everyday
across Paris yeah the Pope seem like I
said Jimmy who's 53 it's very inclusive
is like by eight hours and then goes and
does a little work out that that's what
the books now so it's making it it's
showing people that it is accessible and
not that it is achievable for them to be
able to like go and do a class whereas
in the past it all needs to just be
games games games games games nothing
elite elite guys and then again look at
what we're talking about now they
wouldn't surprise me in fiber turning a
son could you see there being different
drivers of CrossFit gyms would there be
ones where you've got the guys that are
probably compete kind of rustic physique
do you know I mean like CrossFit hounds
and stuff or maybe classes though you
know you guys read my proselytize side
of got going club right yeah
we know which is like a sort of
hypertrophy based eight to twelve
fourteen rep kind of but still using the
methodology right yeah and still kind of
like compound be functionally it's
definitely less functional you know you
pick stuff up off the ground
yeah around you curly you'd waffle up
here your buddy who curls for now yeah
just girls I mean it's an arm wraps its
massive community there's gonna be
people in it that you don't like are
people whose opinions people don't agree
with yeah I know and whether you jump on
board I mean I can imagine Pete it's
some pts I mean not so much now you know
we went because in a weekend cause
that's always a big deal on everyone as
if the city of the personal training
course is that [ __ ] difficult either
do I mean like people just pick up on
these things at all well they bought
with up a gym no yeah I was like yeah we
opened up a gym or Jordan or doubled up
gym and then we spent the next seven or
eight years going on every course we
might be single coach like traveling
like working with people we're gonna be
the high level to get where we are do
you I mean and you know then you did a
level whatever PT couple years ago and
you're still joking himself over it like
step out of your box me a good point is
well pause which I was gonna I was
actually going to mention earlier on
which is reminders of is like with
CrossFit now there's so many different
like certifications that you can do the
certification where everything yeah does
not mean physiology certification is the
winner from certification this you know
kettlebells nutrition there's all this
stuff that a lot of cross the coaches
are gone and do it like I'm not saying
that there isn't there's not many
PT's who work in the commercial sector
without going away on weekends and doing
extra courses but it's a better level 3
yeah you stick that actually spending I
think
I think the I think the fact the matter
is that most of the most of the guys
that are doing a PT stuff have got one
thing on the minds and that is I need to
maximize the money I can make
ready yeah how can i how can I get as
much as there's need for as little as
possible I think that's going to be
anyone in any job there's going to be
other people because that's like saying
that the keys are bad because like
there's some incredible we're looking up
to where people are across the coaches
who really could have been incredible
pts yeah but you know we're looking as
well that they're around us so the more
our combined it about what we do yeah
they know that we've got our jump and
they know that they've got their job
yeah if I wanted to go do a physique
type thing or a bodybuilding thing then
you know those are the guys I saw
getting coached and slice you know I so
boy and put in you know that's people
are gonna be good in it whatever they do
and I just think you know you can't
God's prophets got a brand it's easy you
just tied one of the needs like I know
this without the bands are push-pull leg
your right and then I've sunk into that
get a date on should we just put it down
there should we make one of push/pull
legs there that's just up or on the
tables buy the domain now it's get it
ppl ppl dot-com I'm gonna guess that a
typical CrossFit memberships probably
somewhere between 50 and sometimes a
month well it depends when lobbies okay
so you said that's a good thing to say
so I we when we first opened down I'm
she before we quit now daily quit
yeah because times have changed or
offering more service there's more
competitors where you know we're still
we're still reasonably priced within an
investment in the gym you know
exact my point is that for so that even
at the absolute top end like even if it
was a hundred pounds that's three hours
of PT yeah yeah and when you think you
seriously going going
comparing everything yeah exactly every
day you know this shouldn't sing like
sort of CrossFit is the end that the
only solution to the problem of trying
to get yourself in it but I do think
that there's a number of elements in
that external accountability a level of
intensity that you do not get when you
stay in the gym and then the main thing
for me or one of the main things for me
is that when you see a global gym now
having being in a CrossFit side for so
long you realize that someone's stepped
in with Jim but the headphones it on the
wrong even if they've got a training
partner the headphones are in while
they're doing the snap they start
looking in the mirror
themselves yeah lifting weights steeping
in their own neuroses just wallowing in
it and you just think oh wow like it
doesn't have to be this way genuinely
does not have to be this way not only
can you achieve more in less time that's
exact say it's the time don't get in and
out and I'm 50 my job public is in it in
and out within an hour even like
competitive athletes that we have at the
gym they're not and that's one more than
like two hours to enough hours maybe
have a push
you know like I've watched people in our
gym who come in and train on like the
global side the benefits rounds yeah
what'd you do three hours it just say I
don't know like it seems like there must
be a paradigm shift coming soon as far
as I'm innocent and I think one of the
things is that you have the z0 that I
don't even know what were you ever what
is easier exactly I kind of know it
right okay like the county feels this
vibration who was an Aussie fitness
model yeah dude who's really charismatic
a big YouTube channel I was like [ __ ]
cool guy shredded bit but was come the
the ultimate bro you like the tiny
nothing with it within that even but
this is this whole sort of not like Nike
bodybuilding.com forums like he ran his
name on bodybuilding.com at forums and
there's me and all the rest this stuff
of bits of pieces suddenly died actually
like five years ago and but that was the
beginning of like the aesthetics roll
era like kind of coming back around as
well so as well oh it is trendy to be in
good shape
now do you think it's like like you can
have a jolly show as much as you want
thinks I'm totally shot all the odds on
that good with Nick now everybody wants
to be in good shape
it's trendy it make you cheap but when
you look at clothing if you get muscle
pick clothes
yeah or everywhere the whole I think the
parrot I think you're right isn't the
paradigm is shifting but not just in
like Fitness in like culturally as well
look it's now Frank want to be out of
shape
absolutely absolutely is so I think one
of the things to bring that back around
again is that those guys that were
watching Sears and were like part of
this whole like tiny short string event
long back like Mozy and dancing on the
beach nothing wrong with our gathered in
Gaza
[Music]
flick down fired up you'll see you find
someone but every video and so you had
this you had this kind of era of guys
that was me right so that was me 20 to
23 years old that was me that with those
of the guys I was looking up to dance
the training methodology of reading
stuff like T nation bodybuilding.com
and all the different bits and pieces
like that and then those guys now as far
as I'm concerned you get to your late
20s and you hit a fitness menopause and
I've been saying this for as long as I
can remember now you start to realize
that being leaner all costs is not the
only goal in there yeah and you start to
think [ __ ] chronically away ywír of my
own mortality is over here as I reach
their ear like I need to be able to bend
down and touch my toes yeah I need to be
able to get upset stairs without being
out of breath and it wasn't so long ago
that I was reading stuff from guys
they're doing comp rap and stuff like
that almost take pride in their lack of
fitness yeah yeah and they're like oh do
me like I put my socks on this morning
after arms yesterday and you like dude
like that is that is that's not
something to be proud of I'm glad that
you understand you're wearing not like a
badge of honor yeah but it is your body
telling you that you [ __ ] it either
like I did it I enjoy trying to get fit
but when I was in Globo gym what didn't
anything about Fitness I didn't really
have the guts to go speak to a member of
staff David Dube is he speaking of the
girls or the Jew stuff guys
the Jew stuff guys were just doing their
own thing I was scared to walk me in the
way tell ya like it was it was
terrifying and though I was in on my own
the only thing that had was a copy of
like reading the net waiting for the
next issues of men fitness or men's
health to come up to read and like try
and figure out what many be doing sure I
mean it was like that wasn't social at
all I was pretty lonely
one thing why I think like CrossFit does
so well is because like you accommodated
and you get told what does you you're
not having to go in and think what am I
gonna do today I'm gonna do back in arms
I'm gonna do yeah sure there's in legs
or whatever it's like we come in you get
brought in you get warmed up so you got
give me specific warm for the class that
you're gonna do you then get total
you're gonna do Shore movements you get
run through the class everywhere it's a
high five and they're out the door like
all in an hour so you're getting you're
getting that mega high level of service
and you're not having to think about it
I think that's a big that's definitely a
big deal for me that you can talk
yourself out of going to the gym an
awful lot yeah like you know talk about
it
what are we January seventh today like a
lot of people will be in the party
already broke in the New Year's
resolution they'll be in the midst of
like first week down [ __ ] like this
isn't as easy as I thought it's gonna be
too crazy on fire now probably if the
problem is this isn't as fun as I
thought it was gonna be people probably
trained on Mondays still yeah absolutely
yeah so I didn't go like Quito basically
just ate no cops
but I wasn't eating the strip in advance
in fact I was basically just eating
protein why [ __ ] you gotta [ __ ] Gotha
Jordan Wallace golfer mega fat [ __ ]
I mean I was rock a bit of a dad bod but
I was wrong like super dad bod
so I was like Brian I'm gonna sort out
Jamie first I'm getting done sort of
came in sorting
Timbers on my nutrition Tim Paul doing
my training and then I was like right
Tim I'm on detox getting sword so that
was Tuesday by Friday I was like Tim I'm
awfully sorry I trained on Wednesday and
Thursday and
that and Friday can walk just like
broken but totally broken just by not
eating enough food so um yeah
muffler detox detox is a bad man yeah
good does it see again with that like I
want to do another another podcast that
we focused solely on this but we can
touch on it now about using performance
as CrossFit being able to use
performance as a metric for everything
else that you're doing in your life
because your performance is mitigated by
all of the other influences the app yeah
if I you sleep when you die on your mood
and you rest and your mobility and yet
everything is tested by it yeah whereas
if you're feeling under the weather like
I had that stomach burger to start the
week and I went in easy
yeah I had full-blown yeah we get one
saucy all right that's right yeah so now
spread that spray and you go in and
you're like this is a really quite a lot
harder driver feels like so much we
haven't as usually but if you're hanging
up your ass or you hungover or whether
they say use your hangover is a really
good example if you if you're hungover
and you go in you have to do a class
you're going to know that you're over
the only over you have to go in and
Dubai's by surprise and apps on like
exaggerated body building cetera you can
just dial back the level of our course
efficient example wherever you need and
I think what what's interesting is that
if you were to do if you use CrossFit as
you were growing up to just judge how
you get an on the rest of your life I
must say even all right yeah it's my
relationship with my bird okay like
because my state of mental health when I
get into a workout I have these net like
a lot of negative self-talk that comes
through is that maybe because I've got a
little bit
the negative a home at the moment or
when they're stressed at work because
works going to bother whatever it is
like you use the performance as a
barometer how everything else is going
which is really really useful as opposed
to going in and going light I look to
the Sun Lena today I never got two
percent leaner
yeah and I think one of the one of the
key takeaways for me from CrossFit has
been externalizing your progress
yeah externalizing the progress so
usually what would happen like you could
be doing a cut through a physique
competition and wake up one day 10% lazy
right ask you're right
wake up one day attempt somebody flat
and be in a bad mood and think that you
look really really [ __ ] put to 2% body
fat on and be in a better mood three
weeks later and think if you look good I
think what you're saying there look
Chris was just is cool but all those
things are like subjective completely
subjective where is it CrossFit was
totally a bit subjective like it is it's
completely and you know you can actually
look at the numbers these numbers there
that show you that and that's where they
open that up there yeah exactly
exactly like you can do the open and
2050 and come you know whatever like say
top 10% you do it two years later if you
cover top 8% guess what you've got
better like it's why we do and that's
why we do these benchmark workouts in
the classes like Helen and Fran and all
these things because you can see that
you're getting better and it's you know
nobody can lie about it if you've got
three minutes off so you got five
minutes month one you do again 112 on
your three minutes you got two minutes
better it doesn't matter what they've
got a bad day but an arguably missus
you've had a Burger King whatever you've
got better like and you can't tell me
that I haven't because the proofs in the
pudding it's there five minutes three
minutes they go in underneath where is
all the stuff that you've mentioned like
about deal lock any lien and you know
the guy any bigger it is really very
subjective well that's why I think it's
that's why I think it's so unhealthy and
it leads to people having jaded ideas
about what they should should be doing
with regards to the training yeah that
is so subjective and then let's take it
to the nth degree say you're going to do
a competition you're then externalizing
that's subjectivity yeah because it's
Alonso on is objectively bigger
objectively leaner because its
aesthetics which is very nature
subjective yeah and you think well that
to me just leads to like I'm not
surprised to so much [ __ ] anxiety
yeah like the it studies the cookie
cutter for how they create anxiety and
so on I don't know if I look good enough
I hope that I do yeah you can see on
there Johnny
normally if you if you know if you know
that you can deadlift Sundance or knows
you can deadlift 600 pounds a deadlift
ladder comes up there top weighs 600
pounds
he knows that you can pick it up yeah
okay there's mitigating factors on the
deadlift so would you rather be sticky
or itchy sticky sticky sticky sticky at
least you're sticky you've got you know
religious then just eat junk could just
get worse yeah it's you're only gonna
your own asset stickiness where CrossFit
restart unwrapped scratching we're going
in
exactly right okay would you rather
fight 20 duck sized horses or one
horse-sized one horse-sized the damn
right
20 duck sized horses you know I was the
absorb it easy I want a big don't one
big BB fresh duck sir really does not a
small I thought I just got four legs
what [ __ ] wait go go for is little
legs straight in there like a [ __ ]
kick 20 horse sized dogs all over the
shop as long as he stayed below your
anaerobic threshold you'd be able he's
gotta face it me you gotta came to
spread about follow them follow them any
23 Imam three well three a minute every
minute doesn't it yeah how are you how
are you gonna attack it
I've got parent willing good how are you
going with that's the way ago right how
are you going to attack it though what
do you what's your strategy with this
horse-sized do your agent if you got big
dogs or the other wanna see the bingo
why do you make me zero I have to fight
this do what circumstance clues there I
would probably run away at 30-second
intervals for the one outfit it resting
tiger out a bit but you can do some
pause stop horse
tiger out it would get its massive it so
much muscle that's going to get how I'm
gonna guess the products are you must be
like wait when you cook what are tasty
there's a lot meaning that those going
lock dick to be fair not so much money
you get my horse I don't make a wrapped
with a day
then little pancakes you gonna be loads
but you need a whole cucumber knee drop
just like the second tortilla ah yeah
cucumber dope either side know what you
think but many kids Tesco is doing those
Hausberg isn't they so naturally a
miniature like no money to be made there
anyway there is would you rather be able
to attract any lady you want by wearing
a special magic fedora and saying the
words milady
or be able to run five times your
current speed but you have to put your
arms behind yourself like panic and make
airplane noises I do the bathroom Oh
Sara yeah I just first rep you think
yeah but you can have to go five times
what's supposed to Fred some which you
will indiscreet to the lemon or airplane
noises is worth talkin babies I mean
that's gonna be you gonna be quick
imagine beating everyone in the gym
every time on every wall but it looks
like you're taking the pizzas oh yeah
can you imagine right if that actually
happened and there was a whole school of
coaching that you came out of it
yeah other people will try every night
yeah yeah Finnick pullulan all over
again do you think that it definitely
seems looking for me outside in the
specialists don't you never see well I
mean looking like Matt Fraser for
example like his first and like 2 or 3
years of CrossFit he wouldn't a lot of
competitions but he also didn't do very
well in a lot of competitions because
his things played to his strengths you
could dominate but then if things didn't
he was crippled but then you saw what
he's done is he's taken that and he's
basically worked at those those elements
in the singularity to make them a lot
better so you spent a lot of
a lot of time on the roar a lot of time
that I did it to get better at the sport
it's all transferred over into CrossFit
I suppose the fact when you're talking
about programming is that there's
already a model in place for how to
become a good role yeah we become good
within each of the four areas of fitness
I suppose other categories within which
the workouts go into is how we get good
at deadlift in how we get rid of all of
the different bits and pieces
so really the programmer doesn't that
that's not anything special in terms of
specialist that's just knowledge
deployment like yeah read it read it and
boots inaudible point it together yes I
think it's like okay so you got that
then it's like okay so you've got client
taking a typical like a standard person
we've got period idea so it's like where
are we going to focus on those single
aspects and how we're going to progress
through the year focusing so for us we
start the year with like hypertrophy and
move mechanics cuz we believe in quality
of movement we'll talk and you have to
do veneer after the orbit quality of
movement joint prep because we're going
to load you up in the next cycle and we
need you get strong you know quite far
away from the competition which we know
is like a rocket power and the best
thing it's like then we're gonna load
you up so that's what we're going to hit
you but also we know that we need to
continuously working that Robert bearson
exercise getting all these parts of when
they're suit together an important up
there and then you've got the athlete
who comes to use the individual well
it's okay well where do they need to
bias this where do we need to bias this
cycle or get this guy needs a lot more
strength work so yeah actually this is
going to be a stronger future throughout
it and where something goes in some it
needs to come out so you just need to
balance the program is based on where
that goes in direction for that that
client and athlete or people are or as a
population if it's like a general blog
or something like out the hall the gym
so you need to just look at all those
facets and say actually this is fine so
now we're approaching the open a couple
of those blocks are taken up with spot
now yeah because we're like we've got
three or four spot blocks but we've
still got one block which is like
aerobic power which is single modality
because we still want to be developing
that that but we need to try and fit all
that in with everything else at the same
time yeah Adams going
and putting and pairing movements that
are appropriate
it's like cleans and cleans and their
weave like in a lot of workouts we were
there with like a ring dip or horse to
bar on our bow also puts a little make
quick pull lay dead look good hands down
for juice get lift enhance my push ups
get it like if you if they thought I
mean they might change it before if the
wimple has some push-ups in it would be
with with that lift yeah honestly I am
and all these other movements and yet
always always like paired up with them
so it's gonna say dunno something to be
em tuition what what are the particular
pairings of movements that tend to go
together throws of those polyps those
birdies while it doesn't because there
bro it's a it's there in the same plane
so like a foster and pop they're in the
same place for a trap front squat into
an overhead press and then a pull up as
they pull up so you have in the same
plane but then went in different
directions so yeah basically can't smash
from both ends that's that's what's
happening you don't mean that that is
what it is full an eyeful yeah roof it
through squats matches and snatches a
Muslim or slopes demo just a little high
skill high skill and as you pulling in
that direction mr. Joshua deadlift two
extension into flexion movement some
burpees no it isn't just the bar all
those different combinations it's like
it's the way that the body is moving off
see anything with a burr be in if you're
moving your body through the largest
range of motion possible
Liberty bone all the way down to the
ground and you're getting all the way up
and leaving the ground to anything with
a it's gonna be around if it's a
thruster a gun it slows you down to his
eyes again yeah it's gonna be good so
what we're talking to bring it back to
one of the points that I brought up at
the star but wise cross I saw why does
it look so much like the feeling you're
going through during the workout let's
say that you're doing something like
front which is 2159 of thrusters and
potholes yeah that I think the best
times on the planets are between two and
three minutes for that right now I was
like stop tuna
yeah like I'm in 52 typically to be in a
box you probably put Y like a 10-minute
time company or an 8 minute okay well we
drop it down more like 6 minutes
everyone can kind of get it done enough
she was super short space of time
yeah providing the scale properly yeah
is it like because you love her in an
awful lot so your heart rates high so
that's one of the things that we
contribute to the pain I guess like
fronting for like me for example now
front doesn't really hurt that mouth
because I'm efficient with both of us
that under pull yeah so like when I
first did from I couldn't do 21
thrusters and Logan yeah so 21 thrusters
and broken brutalised this now I could
manage to 40 or 50 reps and broke me
I'll put the bottom don't don't call me
on that but would you know like so it's
not that bad
21 pull-ups might be my Mac set of
polyps now no it's not so it's like I
could do Fran and let's say like 2:30
comfortably yeah but it's that little
extra at the end to get it down like 210
or whatever same what was there much a
roller
yeah which is what brutalizes it and
it's that it's again it's like just the
efficiency of the movie how well this if
you were to put that flag in the ground
that which is being the workout you felt
the worst in and your entire across the
career can you just want come to mind or
Chrisman element okay so the worst or do
some I like the worst ones by far are
basically being the final workout of the
Oakland so 2015 I was like a newer
wasn't gonna qualify but I was I was
just outside of qualification for
regionals as an individual and the last
workout came out I was 27
21:59 thruster calories on the bra and
thrusters so did on the Friday night and
then it was hard but it brutalized it
wasn't that bad did they get on the
Monday
got like 10 seconds fast step but kill
this like I was literally spewing all
over the shop
yeah after that same thing Buster's and
burpees spewed all over this year's
first
double unders spewed all over it's just
that last workout is just so bad and I
think it's like the culmination of the
holes five weeks coming to an end all
the pressure and stress and all that
stuff it just kills me like absolutely
what we saw I was watching you do 17:5
this year which was nine thrusters I
think this was it said thrusters thirty
five and nine yeah at ten ten rounds of
nine thrusters 35mm this yes versus a
point two and Iran saying he'd be due to
Icelandic girls I think I came like
second in Europe on that only thing like
the second the second quickest in Europe
yeah that particular workout yeah
like watching that to me was just like I
don't know it was like there was another
gear that I didn't think that people
were able to get to reach with regards
to that's just one of those things but
that's just a good workout for me yeah
you know I put me do 140 kilos
quadrillions in it that died and
happening you know what I mean but then
you can watch someone like and you know
I've been don't even we've got the gym
Sean boy can pick one for you like this
no yeah it's just it's things that
people go to am lucky that the open
tends to be ninety percent the time to
things that I am good at yeah that's it
it's always it could be anything that as
you start to move towards regionals the
way to get a little bit heavier a lot
more complex the skills get harder the
movements get harder the way to get
heavier and it's a lot it's a lot you
know it's not it's great for someone
like me but then it's better for other
people
mmm-hmm that must be difficult there
must be some athletes than floating
around who would be great or would be
good regionals in games athletes it's
not just can't break through the open
because they get the quickie but it's
the same thanks for you pop you can play
something League who are great you'll
probably go play in the Premiership but
just caught before yeah
it's the season the season starts with
the open like you don't mean like if you
can't get through the open there's a
mile what else you get out because you
pray either
it's clearly a domain and without in a
bunch of movements nobody sit there
going up on the strong guy yeah you're
the slow guy yeah need a [ __ ] slow
guy get get faster get more efficient
and moving you know the things jobs are
all fundamental movements a thruster is
a squat yeah impressive
yeah fundamental movements like you need
to be able move quickly through them so
if you look at the season as in I need
to get this to get to that the season
isn't that the season is the open into
regionals into the games and some
athletes know they're going to get there
because they're already got like all the
stuff in the back yeah and they just
carried out further people I think
there's no point talking about what you
would have done if you got past stage
one should know what a cutter isn't yeah
so many people post awkward it's a k-12
yeah the regionals but also although you
can don't take it what you want but then
what people don't take into account is
them like the fact that not regionals it
is entirely different to do an end the
gym like you know you get your warm via
warming up you've got me no sale next
year like do you realize how
intimidating that is to have like
someone who was the fittest man in the
world at one point warming up on the
Royal exit there's not you gotta contend
with and then you've got the fact that
you've got to go in and sit and sit down
for 15 minutes before you go on the
floor so it's like stuff like that that
people don't realize that you have to do
you have to be there time training I
can't do the money can't do the money on
the ground like just get a coffee and
have another milk or whatever it's like
Nana you will be there at this time you
will perform at this time like enjoy
your American no installation if Castro
for anybody you know what I'm saying you
going on at that time that's it so it's
like all of those things it's it's the
classic the instagrams fall training
complete it's just full of people they
were like the originals what our context
who want regionals what and say how
would it come this that no you would
have done because you have no idea what
the people who were there are going
through and how hard then how hard that
and harsh the environment is in such a
quality way I mean it's like frickin
amazing to get there and to go through
it all but you know it's the context is
completely [ __ ] different let's
totally do if you in Madrid you flan or
whatever are in Copenhagen you flan
whatever they're you're in a pressure
cooker of an environment meetings in
here to treat so yeah and everybody is
like all out giving everything it must
be a very intimidating atmosphere to be
in and I think what's active maybe
there's an atmosphere but I think it's
just very different to you know people
saying oh if I get there I'll smash it
yeah you've got to get that first and
then you can go and see if you can smash
it okay I think what's interesting is
that there's the parallels that you draw
between power lifting like if you've
picked the way to good power lifting
before or in weight lifting or whatever
it is you know that you can pick it up
again yeah I think what makes CrossFit
such a good observers for is that you
can see the narrative of the suffering
going on within the person during the
event you know hey I likely see some
you're on you've got such a short window
someone saw someone running deadlift 300
kilos at a local comp and they either
get it when they don't and it's bring
Joe yeah like within a couple seconds
got three attempts yeah and you like
write a book then you watch someone do
CrossFit and the the spectrum from them
failing or succeeding
something it's so drawn out yeah and
there's such a narrative that's attached
so many variables in there yeah that's
what makes it compelling watch it right
I've also done a very good job of like
how the changed is falling away because
like it used to just be it was a bit of
a [ __ ] show like everyone would just be
doing stuff at the same time
you know where anybody was and someone
would finish it that will finish until
you win whereas now it's like this clear
hair is on the floor why people do
things so you can go how about least 15
reps ahead because they roll the belt
and also like they talk about the
commentators I always talk about the
game just like you've done front now you
know when you watch them on do front
again yeah you know what that feels like
you know what you felt like when you get
that workout or you get those exercises
and you can like completely relate to
someone who even if they're in a
completely different level to you like
or share up in that workout like that
guy except me how the [ __ ] did he do it
five minutes quicker than me yeah I mean
and I'm good work and but you can relate
you can see you okay sure because you
even even if nothing else if you compare
your compare alongside our person even
if it's a different part of world and
like it didn't believe I think that's
one of the views of the olden day the
work now is issued and every one person
who just started two weeks ago to the
best guys on the planet have to do it
and to me always seems impressively I
mean how many people to deal with over
half a billion it was like four hundred
thousand things not falling on that
around either
four hundred thousand people did it
worldwide and the guys that came top it
Matt what all renowned names yeah you
don't mean like Noah ohlsen is always
going to be tough I'd like and you think
out of all the variables that are going
on in life and he's such a wide net of
things that can go on and it can go
wrong
and these guys are still so dominant
with what they do that you can give them
this time we air maybe it's well within
their capacities or whatever because
it's a it's a easy workout there's so
much further they're meant to be at the
games they will do granny open that
people that people not do well at the
games tend to do well in the open and do
well at Regionals like and it's really
it's really a final round from the open
the smashes the fittest people it does
especially now that the man who didn't
like the heavy elements and the master
used to all be liked and it didn't find
the fittest people because like for
example for me in 2015 one max clean
and I came like fifty three parts of the
workout first workout I think I came
ninth the second one I came back 400
yeah
I'm not fit it's not easy I'm just not
fit enough they go you don't mean that
there's no it's black or white I'm fit
or not and I wasn't so then I didn't go
that yeah but then 2016 came along and
there was a heavier workout but it was
blended with other skills so it was like
heavier work I happy a lift but with
inner work out so it was a blend of your
ability to touch the ball double under
and then wrap a heavy barbell and when
that came out I was able to I still had
a terrible finish that came back hundred
knees and Europe or whatever but I was
still it that was still high enough to
around meter then I guess the next day
something that's slightly less
partitioned will weed out people as
specialists a little bit more active as
well so the point I'm trying to make
there was it found the fittest people
you know you complain about and go well
it was a heavy work aren't prepared for
it well know how to fit there I you
stronger my fitness was more rounded I
wouldn't be known right yeah so
identified a massive gaping hole in my
fitness and people find that every year
you know like the dumbbells totally trip
people up this year but I said you know
people spent all last year doing
percentage lifts percent it's not super
percentage queens 20 kilo dumbbell
master mom still hundred and fifty reps
of the most natural broken people
getting like 20 minutes on that first
workout people who would previously be
in the regionals previously competed at
a high level just got right on the bus
not sure what you do it's a muscle
that's a massive everything you get
messages like would accrue [ __ ] without
a barbell and I was already killed up
you know it wasn't like 22 and off you
know flew you back off your boo-boo you
know I mean get a group I think I think
that what's what's really really funny
to see is that this the really isn't
know where I hide is that now with
regards to like when people have
underperformed like I guess bad judging
like if you get absolutely nailed by a
judge who doesn't understand
standards but that doesn't seem to
really happen all that much and
regionals and every games aside from
that like that goes both ways though I
mean you get that off your stuff as well
yeah you get penalized first you win
that nobody's they wouldn't we lose this
is business right leg in the turn we get
what you saying is really right that if
someone [ __ ] it did [ __ ] it like you
think about the dumbbells like I'm right
saying there was no barbells even in
regionals either well the only barbell
workout in this year in the open was the
deadlift yeah and then there was a Scots
national someone's not yet correct the
last three year yeah and regionals it
was it was all done yet that was it was
a region regionally to the diamond Obama
deep wall as well so I've had to put the
ball in those heavy cowbells heavy has a
little emotion which is [ __ ] and he
saw someone like Alec Smith who has
struggled all the games in the past when
that stuff comes up that he's really
good up blends his region bitties
brother Ben Smith he was like the first
Mountaineers in 2015 because he's good
at that stuff and so it shows you that
like even though you have to be good at
everything
if you've got specific things and you
will excel in seven years it's why
someone like frohnen and Fraser was so
impressive because they win year on yeah
doesn't matter about the program yeah
they win you don't I mean all we do is
with all these will win them our guys
very much
look anyway we're gonna do this again a
number of times but thank you very much
for you time we don't make nutrition in
Reebok Russert I'm side Phillip North
morning programming all those bits will
be in the description and thank you go
[Music]